-Performing "Skin and Bones"
from her new album,
"You Can't Kill Me,"
give it up for 070 Shake!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah.
Yeah.
♪ And we spoke in past tense ♪
♪ Reminisce 'bout back when ♪
♪ Our spirits used to
dance with each other ♪
♪ We been smoking gas, yeah ♪
♪ This is so romantic ♪
♪ I never wanna press
fast-forward ♪
♪ You treat me like I'm more
than a pair of skin and bones ♪
♪ And that really made
a difference in my story ♪
♪ Say life will take its toll ♪
♪ But whichever way we go ♪
♪ Know I'm right here by
your side, shawty ♪
♪ Skin and bones
under the covers ♪
♪ Kept our love undercover ♪
♪ Nonchalant, very subtle ♪
♪ Tryin' not to step on
the puddle ♪
♪ Write on your flesh ♪
♪ With permanent ink ♪
♪ Light the incense ♪
♪ Remember this scent ♪
♪ High as a bitch ♪
♪ But you won't catch me slip ♪
♪ I know nothing ♪
♪ I know I don't ♪
♪ And we spoke in past tense ♪
♪ Reminisce 'bout back when ♪
♪ Used to dance with
each other ♪
♪ We been smoking gas, yeah ♪
♪ This is so romantic ♪
♪ I never wanna press
fast-forward ♪
♪ You treat me like I'm more
than a pair of skin and bones ♪
♪ And that really made
a difference in my story ♪
♪ Life will take its toll ♪
♪ But whichever way we go ♪
♪ Know I'm right here ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Skin and bones
under the covers ♪
♪ Kept our love undercover ♪
♪ Nonchalant, very subtle ♪
♪ Tryin' not to step on
the puddle ♪
♪ Right enough,
I thought I'd let you know ♪
♪ I'm tryin' not to
hide undercover ♪
♪ High enough,
I thought our love was so ♪
♪ Tryin' not ♪
♪ You treat me like I'm more
than a pair of skin and bones ♪
♪ And that really made
a difference in my story ♪
♪ Life will take its toll ♪
♪ Whichever way we go ♪
♪ By your side ♪
♪♪
♪ What a contrast ♪
♪ My skin and bones against
the color of your aura ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ On a Sunday ♪
♪ Walkin' slow
while time was still runnin' ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ The moon's favorite daughter ♪
♪ Light in the dark
and the waves in the water ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ If I can't be brave ♪
♪ And let you walk away ♪
♪ Maybe next life,
you'll be mine again ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Mine again ♪
♪ Oh, no ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]